We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P..
Here's a seemingly simple question about Trump.
Take a listen.
Oh, David.
I just wanted to get your take on why no one
is calling for Trencher resignation at this
point.
In the midst of all the crap that he's done.
Thank you.
Right.
So, listen, you and I know that Donald Trump
has done, you know, enough to warrant 10 resignations
and five impeachments at this point.
I don't know that there's much of a benefit
to calling for his resignation.
The election's in four months.
Right.
I mean, we if we reelect him, if the country
reelect him after everything that's gone on,
clearly the whack jobs are in the majority.
I mean, there's just and we're going to have
to figure out some other way to fix the country.
I don't know that there's much value in calling
for resignation now.
I think we should focus on let's just get
this guy out.
We're four months away.
He could be out in six and we could have a
different president.
That's where I'm not denying he should resign.
I'm not denying he should have been impeached
at this point.
I don't know what what we're really hoping
for because it's not going to happen.
It's not going to happen.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
We'll talk about the Seattle protest zone.
We will talk about the roadblock to electric
vehicles and America's future.
It's not a bad roadblock.
We'll talk about it and much, much more.
Join me on the bonus show by becoming a member
at join Pacman dot com or a patron at Patrie
on dot com slash David Pakman show.
I'll see you then.